Alright, so say that we've determined the coefficients for a linear
model for our data using gradient descent, or even some other
method. Just because we're able to come up with some model
doesn't mean that it's a good one. The data could be distinctly
non-linear. Or, maybe the attributes that we've trained our model on
have little to no bearing on our output variable. We need
some way to evaluate the effectiveness of our model. One way
we can measure this is a quantity called the coefficient of determination,
also referred to as R squared. If we have
a bunch of values, yi through yn. A bunch
of predictions, fi through fn and an average value
for our data, y bar. We can define the
coefficient of determination as R squared is equal to
1 minus the sum over n of yi minus
fi squared, over the sum over n of yi
minus y bar squared. The closer R squared is to
one, the better our model. And the closer it is to zero, the poorer our model.
The coefficient of determination gives us a pretty
effective way to evaluate how good our model is.